[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: I'm a product
manager in cloud networking.
I work on a bunch of
different technologies,
including related to
cloud load balancing CDN
and, more recently, on-service
mesh and some of the newer
paradigms.
And one of the reasons we put
this panel together is there
are several talks where
we talk about products.
So we talk about solutions.
And everywhere,
the theme is open.
And it's hybrid, and it's
enabling new businesses.
Nowhere have we really
paused to really say, OK,
what does open mean?
Especially, it might
mean different things
to a different set of people.
And then what are
the commonalities
amongst all of those people?
What are they trying to achieve?
And so I thought I'd get four
very unique perspectives.
I'll let these folks
introduce themselves.
But let's see what
open means to them,
and then we will also have a Q&A
for 15 minutes in the middle,
where you get a chance
to ask them questions.
So I'll call that out once
we get to that section.
But with that, I'd like to start
with our first panelist, Anna.
And introduce yourself.
ANNA BERENBERG: Hi,
I'm Anna Berenberg,
and I'm a tech lead
for load balancing,
and one of the product today
was announced, Traffic Director.
I've been at Google
13 years, and Prajakta
is my partner in crime.
We work together on
a lot of products.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Hi,
I'm Kelsey Hightower.
I'm kind of a generalist these
days at Google, focused mainly
on containers and
now serverless stuff
and have to deal
with these folks
to get the networking
the way I want it.
And they're great, too.
MATT KLEIN: Hey, everyone.
My name is Matt Klein.
I'm a software
engineer at Lyft, where
I work mostly on
infrastructure and networking.
I spend a lot of time these
days working on a network
proxy called Envoy.
BIKASH KOLEY: Bikash Koley, I'm
the CTO of Juniper Networks.
Before that, I spent
almost 10 years
at Google building
the production network
that a lot of the
Google services run on.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI:
I'll probably just
add some more, because
they've been extremely modest.
So Anna drives a lot of cloud
networking from the inside.
She's one of the seven
distinguished engineer
females at Google.
Kelsey is the face of Kubernetes
and Cloud Run and now Istio
and a whole bunch of things.
Matt is the one who
developed Envoy at Lyft.
And Bikash is the
one who developed
all of Google's
infrastructure and now is
doing the same at Juniper.
So I'm really excited
to have them here.
I wanted to start
the question-- and we
can keep it free
flowing, but I wanted
to start off this panel
with a question, which
is, we talk so often about open,
and we talk about open systems.
Does it really mean systems?
Does it mean APIs?
Does it mean something else?
I wanted to get your perspective
on what open means for you.
And maybe we start from
that end this time.
So maybe, Bikash, we
can start with you.
BIKASH KOLEY: OK.
Thank you.
So open, from my
perspective, I see
three layers of open as it
starts with open standards,
goes to open API, then
it goes to open source.
And from our perspective,
it's ultimately something
that the customers
increasingly want, or need,
or demand from the
perspective of how do I
get innovation velocity?
How do I have control
on what I'm actually
deploying on my
infrastructure without having
the supplier of the
technology having to do that?
And how do I ensure security?
How do I get the maximum
number of eyes on the product
that we're building?
So open cuts through that
layer, but increasingly, it's
a business need.
That's how I see it.
MATT KLEIN: Yeah, that
was a fantastic answer.
Probably would have been
pretty close to my own.
I think the thing that I would
add is, open, to me, it also--
via open APIs, open source,
all of those things,
it allows us to build
more powerful platforms.
So one of the
things that I think
we've been able to
do with Envoy is,
because we have so many
companies and people adopting
it, we're seeing a
cycle of essentially
vertical applications
that are starting
to form around that technology.
And I think whereas
historically we
have competing proprietary
technologies that
tend to focus their efforts
on a very singular fashion.
Now, yes, we can compete
on vertical axes.
But it allows us, I think, to
actually make more progress.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
I think, for me, I
used to say it was kind
of rooted in open source.
These days, I care
a little bit less
about that as long
as I can solve
my own problems without waiting
for the vendor to do it for me.
If I can get that
in proprietary,
or open, or open
source project, I
feel that gives me the power
to solve my own problems.
So I think that's
the key tenet for me
because there's some open
source projects, where
you can't actually extend it
to solve your own problems.
So that doesn't necessarily
fit the bill for me.
ANNA BERENBERG: Three for
me-- it's operatability,
interoperability,
and open standards.
All of them are because we want
our customers to write code
once and run it everywhere.
As you heard probably yesterday
and today about Anthos.
It's the same thing, right?
Basically, what we want,
we want to build systems,
that whole underneath
horizontals where you can--
on which you can build your
business logic, one workload.
And because of portability
on underlying systems,
you can run it on-prem
and on multiple clouds.
Also, about
interoperability, that
means that control planes need
to talk to each other, right?
Because just running
it on each cloud
separately doesn't
help you to make it
into a single deployment,
which you also want to have.
And how you can do it?
You can do it only
with open standards,
because nobody wants
a vendor lock-in.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Actually,
that is interesting.
And when I take your
definitions of open,
and then I think back to a lot
of the open technologies each
of you has been
involved in, I think,
what would be really
fascinating for the audience,
because it's
fascinating for me, is--
so just as an
example, Matt, you've
been involved with Envoy.
I used to always
wonder, why didn't you
not make a startup out of it?
You could have had this
really fancy startup.
So in my mind, the
question-- and I'm
sure a lot of folks
in the audience
as well-- is, these
open source products
that you've been involved,
what was the starting point
for them?
How did you think of them?
How did they end up
landing in open source?
What was your journey,
and what do you
think you would have done
differently, in retrospect,
for those projects?
And maybe we can
start with you, Matt.
MATT KLEIN: Sure, yeah.
So I think, one of the things
that has made Envoy so popular
is that it wasn't
started as a product
that we were going to sell.
We developed it at Lyft to solve
particular customer problems.
I've worked in the networking
space for quite some years,
and I had a feeling that
maybe this thing would
be useful to folks outside.
I did not understand what would
happen once we open sourced.
It's been a really
incredible journey.
But that question of starting
a company and being open,
it's one that's
top of mind to me,
and I could talk for a
very long time about this,
so I'll stop myself.
But I think the key
is, a lot of people
right now are trying to
understand how to make money
around open source.
It's a very complicated topic.
And I think there's two
things that are often at odds,
and those are about
having open technologies,
building a larger community.
And very often,
when you're trying
to make money on something
in a singular fashion,
you might be looking
at business models,
like open core, where
you're blocking features.
And that tends to antagonize
the larger community.
So when people ask
me about, hey, Matt,
why didn't you go
and start a company.
We can talk after,
but I don't think
Envoy would be what it is
today if I had left and started
a company.
We would not have
all three major cloud
providers using Envoy.
We wouldn't have tons of
companies building products
on top of Envoy
because they would all
be competing with
me and my company,
and that does not make a
larger and vibrant community.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: And I think--
I mean, that's a really
interesting perspective.
And I wanted to add in
Bikash's perspective.
He comes from a
vendor, and then you've
had your journey
with OpenContrail,
which is now Tungsten Fabric.
And it's a little bit different
from what Matt described.
So can you take us through that?
What is Juniper?
What were you thinking as you
took it through that journey?
BIKASH KOLEY: Yeah,
so Tungsten Fabric,
which originated in
Contrail five-plus years
back, the reason that it was
open sourced, as OpenContrail,
in those days, was, because
the customers actually
asked Juniper to do it.
And the reason is sort
of what I described
before, that, ultimately,
especially in this space,
companies come, companies go.
When somebody is investing their
core infrastructure examples
would be very large carriers.
All of their calls go
over this infrastructure.
When you are betting that
mission-critical application
on something, you
want to, ultimately,
control your own destiny
one way or the other.
And having a code
base that's open
allows you to, ultimately,
control your own destiny,
if you have to, at that point.
It has come a long way.
And really, what
our vision is now
with Tungsten Fabric, the
reason that it changed
from OpenContrail
to Tungsten Fabric,
is I believe that the new cloud
stack is built on open source.
It starts from Linux
to KVM to Kubernetes.
Even before that, OpenStack,
OpenShift, or [INAUDIBLE],,
and so on and so forth.
It's built on open source.
This stack needs
a networking stack
that doesn't make assumption
as to where your workload is,
or which cloud it's running
on, or where it's deployed,
or whether it's
greenfield or brownfield.
I mean, as much as all of us
would love all the applications
to be containerized
and service mesh best,
a large part of the world
still runs their application
on bare metal.
Now how do you get that
deployment on the same network
stack that allows
you to actually move
and migrate very quickly to
the modern ways of writing
application, but you
don't leave things behind?
And I saw that
stack was missing.
There were a lot of
networking stacks
that were designed for
very specific things.
But there isn't an
open source stack
that actually allows you
to do all of this together.
And frankly, if you are
trying to go into multicloud,
and if you're serious
about it, multicloud
are the largest public clouds.
But they're also open style.
They're also VMware.
They're also bare metal
cloud that they have built.
So we saw the need,
and we saw the gap.
And it was it was sort of
the obvious thing for us
to sort of expand the
open source charter
that OpenContrail had
into Tungsten Fabric.
And it has been a
fabulous journey.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Awesome.
Now, I'm taking you back to some
of the early days of Google.
And I know, Kelsey, you've been
heavily involved in Kubernetes
for a really, really long time.
In my mind, you are
the face of Kubernetes,
and then now, this Cloud Run
and a bunch of new things
you're playing around with.
When you think of
Kubernetes, I hear
you speak very
passionately on the topic.
What is that journey?
And then what were the tenets
in mind, where you said,
oh, it's going to solve this
set of problems really well?
And I also know there are
certain cases where you say,
do not use Kubernetes there.
So I actually want to hear
of it from the beginning.
So what got you into Kubernetes?
What was the fascinating
aspect of it, the community,
and so on?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So I
think, early with Kubernetes,
it's Google's entry
into the container place
where they have the most
background and expertise
at that particular
checkpoint, right?
So Docker is dominant.
I'm at CoreOS.
There's a startup trying to
build Google's infrastructure
for everyone else.
And then Google comes along
and does exactly that.
So if you recognize that,
if that was your mission,
and it's now playing out--
and Google was very inviting.
I was able to contribute,
get things merged in.
And at that
particular time, there
was this kind of friendly
war, the container wars.
Lots of us have scars from
the container war days.
And we were all trying to
capitalize on this ability
to package your app and run
it in a very consistent way.
But that wasn't
necessarily solved
across multiple machines.
And Kubernetes added
a lot of features
to make that as easy
as possible, ideally,
competing with things
like Docker Swarm,
Nomad, all of these
kind of easy-to-use,
distributed
computing things that
just try to make your
environment look like something
like App Engine.
There was one
pivotal point where
we understood that the
power of Kubernetes
was not going to just be that.
I remember, we were doing some
empathy sessions internally.
And one thing that was very
clear is that Kubernetes API
and when we added CRDs,
Custom Resource Definitions,
to me, that was the
biggest game-changer.
Kubernetes is not just
a container runtime.
That's the first system that
was built on top of Kubernetes.
So there was a
phrase that I said.
It's Kubernetes is as a
platform for building platforms.
The thing about having
APIs and extensions,
of course, you can extend it.
But you can only do what
the interface provides.
Hey, here's a network extension.
You can only do with
the interface provides.
In the Kubernetes world was
we made it a very first-class
thing to make custom
extensions that
had nothing to do with
the rest of the platform.
You want to build
a CI/CD system?
Make a CRD, and we would
generate all the client
bindings.
Our back will be applied,
even to your custom extension.
So we became a framework
for building extensions.
And that's very different than
just having a plugin interface
over a limited framework.
And that was key,
to me, of letting
people solve their problems.
So to me, it wasn't just
because Kubernetes was open.
It was because it was this
open framework for you
to solve any problem that
you wanted to, regardless
if you got community
consensus or not.
I think that was the pivotal
point when Kubernetes
took a life of its own.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: And
coming to Anna, the reason
I saved Anna for the last is
I have a lot of visibility
into some of the systems
she's built at Google.
Oftentimes.
we hear that, oh, but
we are not Google.
And I think, a lot
of the paradigms that
were built at Google
are not necessarily
meant only for Google.
And a lot of the
systems were born,
where we wanted to
abstract away the toil,
but then still give you
all of the benefits, so you
can have the same benefits
for your services.
And so I wanted
Anna to just talk
a little bit about the systems
you built, for instance,
12 years back.
And now, you're building
systems out for cloud.
How do you see that journey?
What kind of systems are they?
How different are
they today from what
you built 12 years back?
ANNA BERENBERG: Well,
I started in 2006.
And at the time, Google had
couple data centers, maybe
three, four at the time,
maybe a little more.
But we had a load balancer,
and the load balancer
that was in place was a
[? square ?] load balancer,
and it was falling in pieces.
So we build totally new control
plane load balancer global
that done wonderful work.
And we organically grew it
based on the experiences
with these big
customers that we had,
which was Web Search,
YouTube, Gmail, each of which
had a very different
requirements.
But most of them turned
into requirements
that are pretty much
common to everybody else.
They want to send data
as fast as possible.
They want to minimize
the round-trip time
for overall traffic globally.
They want to make sure they
can run their workload as
cheap as possible.
So that means that they want
load balancer to distribute
traffic in a way that it will
optimize overall capacity.
And they want to make sure
they can control and debug
things, so their
administrative tools that
built into the traffic
management and stuff.
And we thought, this
is so Google, right?
And then we go into
Cloud, and guess what.
Our customers wanted the same.
The interesting thing, though,
that we learned a lot about it
over years.
And the customers are
pretty sophisticated,
and they want just
right this, this moment,
exactly this that we built
over such a long time.
So it's not like Google
is very different.
We were a little
isolated and lived
in this self kind of bubble.
And the customers'
needs growing very fast,
and their requirements
are outpacing
at this point internal
Google requirements, which
is interesting.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Sounds great.
And then just building
on what Bikash said,
one of the interesting
things he said
is, as much as we want
all of these technologies
to appear in our networks and
our deployments, the world--
I mean, there is a lot
of existing deployments.
And we need to figure out
how to get these deployments
to whatever is the
end state based
on the goals of the customers.
Now one of the things
I hear about all
of these technologies--
and I actually believe it,
but I also hear
about it-- is they
are providing a lot of ways to
solve the challenges that we
face in a multicloud world.
And even when we look
at cloud customers,
and I'm sure, as you look
at your own requirements,
you probably have a
deployment on-prem.
And then you are
in Google Cloud,
and you're likely in
other clouds as well.
And then it's extremely hard
to deploy and manage these.
So one of the questions-- and I
want to see what their opinion
is--
do you believe fundamentally
that these systems
can be game-changers
for enabling you
to deploy services,
manage them seamlessly?
Is there a big gap
that needs to be
filled before we can say that?
What is your take on that?
And any of you can start.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: I think
the biggest problem--
we've seen this--
every time there's new
technology that comes out,
there are some people who buy
what the vendor is selling.
They read the blog post.
They copy and
paste and retrofit,
not really understanding
the fundamentals.
There are people who
understand the fundamentals,
and look at these new
tools, and evaluate them
on their ability
to solve problems
in that fundamental space.
I think the challenge is, we
have so many tools coming out
now, the pace of those tools.
And you get really
confused if you don't
know what the fundamentals are.
At the fundamental, you can look
at Nginx, HAProxy, and Envoy
as doing very basically
the same thing.
And there's a higher
level fundamental
around configuration.
How do you configure things?
Most people are familiar with
configuring these via file
and restarting something.
And you look at Envoy,
and you say, wow,
this XTS protocol to
incrementally configure
a thing live, that's a big
transition for most people.
So that's how I fundamentally
look at these things
based on fundamentals
and say, wow, Envoy
is really bringing
something new to the table.
Fundamentally, it's
routing packets around.
But there's something
different in the way you think.
In order to take advantage
of something like Envoy,
you have to
understand, the ability
to configure something that sits
in the network the way it is
sets the stage for things like
Istio and Traffic Director.
Without that
understanding, all of this
just looks like
noise and confusion,
and then someone has
to try to convince you.
And I think,
unfortunately, we've
been trying to do that to
the sales motion and not
the engineering
emotion of saying,
this is what these
things actually are.
Here's what they do.
And it's OK if you want to
outsource that to someone.
But you got to understand
what that technology is first,
so you can take advantage of it.
MATT KLEIN: Yeah, I
think the biggest problem
that I see is, like Kelsey said,
there's so many technologies
coming out right now.
And there's this tension that
we have from the tools, where--
and I see this all
the time with Envoy--
where we have a section of
people that come to Envoy.
And they'll say, I
don't understand this.
It's too complicated.
There's too many
configuration options.
I just don't even
know where to start.
And then we have another set
of people that come and build
absolutely incredible
things that blow my mind
without ever talking to me or
anyone else on the project.
So we have this tension.
Clearly, we have
many different users,
from people that want a
prepackaged solution to people
that want an extensible solution
to build vertical things.
And
I think the key takeaway for
me is that there is never
going to be a one thing that
fits every possible end case.
And I think that, from
the infrastructure side,
we have to build
layered solutions.
So there's going
to be something,
like Kubernetes, or like Envoy,
which is more of a platform.
And then we might have vertical
solutions on top of that.
And then we might have pass
or functional platforms that
sit on top and or
more opinionated,
as we actually get
further up the stack.
And I think, right
now, we're still
in that very early days of
creating a lot of tools,
and there's a lot of
confused people out there.
And I think we have
to iterate to find
the right layers
of abstraction, so
that people can tap
in at the layer that's
most appropriate for them.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: I
want to add one thing.
And I see this a
lot with technology.
When new technology
comes out, there's
a large population
in the tech world
that wants the new thing
to work the old way.
And this is what really slows
down some of these projects,
some of the momentum.
You start adding a lot of
cruft to these projects,
that they shouldn't
be doing these things.
But in an attempt to
grow your user base,
sometimes you will try to
retrofit this new thing that
has bought into
this new paradigm
to solve the old problems.
And sometimes, you just got
to draw the line and say, no.
That's not what this thing does,
even if it does cost market
share or different use cases.
BIKASH KOLEY: So I am
a technologist just
like everybody
else in the panel.
I'll share a slightly
different perspective.
I spend a lot of time in
my role with customers.
And I think, as technologists,
we often forget usability.
We go after look how cool this
thing is with what it does,
but not how it actually
solves a customer's problem.
You sort of touched upon
that in the abstraction,
but it's actually
more than abstraction.
If we don't understand
the current state
of an infrastructure
of a customer,
and if we show them the
shining city on the hill,
and we don't show them the
steps to get to the shining
city on the hill,
and we tell them,
by the way, where you live
today, condemned house,
forget it.
It's not reality.
It's not reality
for any one of us.
I have yet to see--
and I can only
speak from network.
I've built infrastructure
for a long time at Google.
I speak to a lot of
customers all the time.
I've yet to see a single
instance of a greenfield
infrastructure.
It doesn't exist.
It's fantasy.
So if it is fantasy,
then the reality is,
we've got to build the steps.
If we don't build the
steps in technology,
it doesn't matter how cool the
shining city on the hill is.
It's never going to be real.
My view is that the
technology world has often
ignored the steps.
And that does not
mean that you actually
drag your old broken house
up to the shining city.
But it means that you give a
way to get to there instead,
where you are not layering
yet another set of tools, yet
another set of infrastructure.
Unfortunately,
one of the reasons
for the explosion
of the tools is
because we haven't quite solved
the old, and we have a new one.
And so we have layered
yet another tool, right?
If I happen to
have infrastructure
that must run on my
15-year-old database,
because that's where
I have 100 million
of my customers'
information, no way I
can migrate to something
else in the next five years.
Well, I still have to run that.
And if I tell them that you're
going to run that in the way
that we ran 15 years back,
which was throwing people at it,
but you have all these new
shiny applications that
is fully-automated,
intent-driven, policy-operated,
and this is a new way of
training your workforce
and operators, I don't
think that's real.
Because I don't think anybody
has money to actually do it.
One of the beauty of public
cloud is that underneath,
the infrastructure
always changes.
The stable APIs hide that.
I know for a fact that GCP
seven years back is not
what GCP is today with
the infrastructure
that it has underneath.
But if somebody used APIs
on GCP, most of those APIs
are still the same.
I think, when the
tools start doing that,
where it's not really
forgetting the migration, that's
an important part
for us to solve.
We are definitely focusing a lot
on that with Tungsten Fabric,
because most of the
customers that we see,
they absolutely want the
worldwide service mesh
where security is not
a networking thing.
Security is an
application thing.
But they also run most of their
applications on bare metal,
maybe on VM in some scenarios.
And if I tell them that
your policy construct
for our service mesh is
this, but in the old way,
you're still configuring
firewall policies,
OK, we haven't really
solved the problem for them.
So I actually do
believe that bridging
the gap between
the old and the new
is a critically important
component of the technology.
And those that will
do it, they'll win.
Because the customers need that.
ANNA BERENBERG: Some
time ago, I set up
to build intent-driven
configuration
system for service management.
It turned out into
success, but it only
worked-- for 50% of services
worked well, for 35%,
it worked somewhat, and
it didn't work for 15%.
And those 15% were probably
the most important one.
They're big.
They need every little
knob you can even think of.
And with that, I understood
that we need everything.
We need the knobs
as the foundation,
and we need to
have them exposed.
We need a simpler configuration
on the top to help the 35%,
and we do need intent.
So I think we're at a
point in the cloud era
where we're still
at the knob level.
And I think if we
do the knobs well,
then the verticals on the top of
it and the intent-based system
will grow next.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: I
want to add one thing.
So before coming to Google, I've
been in your position, trying
to manage infrastructure.
Maybe you share
the same opinion.
From a provider, we have
to try to support everyone.
When you're at your own
company, you only care kind of
about your use case, right?
I've been in cases, where we
burnt the whole house down,
so we can have the new one.
And it's painful.
Not everyone can do it.
But you can do it.
But as providers,
we are kind of stuck
in this situation where
we're trying to go out
of a large market share.
So we kind of have
these tug of wars
internally on what the
feature set should be.
And I think there's just
different people who
are concerned with
different parts of that.
When I looked at Envoy, I
looked at it as a clean start.
There's a clean start here to
solve a very unique use case.
I think Docker came from the
same thing as a clean start
to solve a unique use case.
And then once it gets
mass adoption, I think,
you start to have the
ecosystems show up.
And there are people who will
help you adopt that thing,
build a bridge technology.
But I hope that we are free to
continue to build things that
don't work in the old world.
And then maybe someone
will come and bridge it.
But I don't want us
to try to figure out
how to bridge everything.
Because I think it will stifle
new ways of doing things,
because we're always
constantly stuck
with the 20-year-old decisions.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So I'm going
to open it up to audience.
Before that, I pulled
out a bunch of questions
from the Dory, and then also
from LinkedIn and Twitter.
And there's some really
interesting questions.
There was one for
you, Kelsey, that
said, how do you become
good at so many open source
technologies?
These people are having probably
some fan club out there.
But they're having hard
time just getting their arms
around Kubernetes,
and then you're
already onto Cloud Run and
a bunch of different things.
So how do you do that?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: So 10 years
ago, I came to the conclusion
that there is probably
nothing new, period.
It isn't.
There's data that comes in.
You do something with the data,
and you put it somewhere else.
Oh MySQL, Oracle, Spanner--
doesn't matter.
They all have their
own little protocol.
They're going to store
your data in some format.
The bytes are the same.
I know you want to say is
cloud native, or new, or old.
Legacy, it's all noise to me.
There's the fundamentals.
So when I look at
the fundamentals,
bytes are moving around.
How do you want to
move your bytes?
You want to move it with Envoy?
Envoy has to move the
same bytes in the same way
that everything else has.
It's free to have
a new interface.
It's free to do different
performance things.
But at the end of
the day, those bytes
have to flow in a certain
set of directions.
That's it.
So when I see new technology
that comes out for networking,
it's very simple.
These bytes need to go
from point A to point B.
What are you going to
do with those bytes?
And the same thing
is true for compute.
You're going to call, instruct
in sets on this kernel,
on this CPU.
You want to do it with Golang?
You want to do it with Python?
You want to do it with Docker?
At the end of the
day, you're just
going to make some system calls.
I never get tripped up and
confused with the noise.
I just want to know,
how are you going
to do the fundamental thing?
And that's how I find bugs,
and that's how I work through.
That's all it ever can
be is the fundamentals.
And then if you respect that,
and you learn the fundamentals,
any new technology
that comes out,
you only have to
ask one question.
How are you implementing
the fundamentals?
And then that's my
secret to doing that.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: There's another
question that-- so I'm going--
I've been pulling these
out of LinkedIn and Twitter
that came for Matt.
You developed a wonderful
open, like a data plane proxy.
Why did you not build out the
control plane in open source?
MATT KLEIN: That's
a great question,
and it actually
comes back to what
we were talking about before.
It's Envoy is a very
general technology.
And it's extensible.
It has a bunch of APIs.
Like I was saying
before, we've seen
it adopted in a tremendous
amount of use cases.
And like Anna was saying, if
it didn't have all the knobs,
if it wasn't that base
piece of technology,
it would not have been
adopted in all these cases.
What you find at
Lyft is that we have
a control plane based on Envoy.
We built Envoy, so
the control plane
has built up over the
last three or four years.
The control plane's a
little embarrassing.
I would not open source it.
It's a mishmash of, like, Python
templating, and Bash, and Go.
I mean, you all understand
how these things go.
And my point is that we don't
expose all of the Envoy knobs
to people at Lyft.
We have service manifests.
We have a configuration
generator.
We do all these things,
so that people at Lyft
only see a very tiny subset
of the Envoy configuration.
But that also means that
the control plane at Lyft
is very specific to Lyft.
I work for Lyft.
I'm not building a product.
And it just doesn't
make sense to invest
in trying to clean up that
control plane in a way
to open source it.
That doesn't mean that we
haven't open sourced libraries.
There are libraries that we
support in Envoy open source,
like Go control plane
and Java control plane.
These are foundational
libraries.
But they're not
complete solutions,
because they depend on our
Jenkins, and our Kubernetes,
and our Legacy VM
infrastructure.
Because we're not, of course,
not only on Kubernetes.
So it's really, again,
just about those
layered abstractions.
And it just doesn't
make sense for us
to invest in open sourcing
that control plane.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So
there's another question.
Thank you, Matt.
And there's a
question for Bikash.
So this person is
a Twitter user.
The person says that you
built these massive systems
at Google, and they've
been to all of your talks.
They're like, now, as you are
at Juniper, which learnings
are you utilizing at Juniper?
And what are you
doing differently?
BIKASH KOLEY: Yeah,
I think the best way
that I can describe this is,
building systems in Google
has certain expectations
with who your customers are.
And those customers inside of
Google, they're very savvy.
They're very tech savvy.
So you want to
expose all the knobs.
You want to make it
highly programmable.
You expect that there is a
[? suite ?] on the other side
of the system, who
is doing something
very meaningful with the
system that you've built.
In many of the
customers, the level
of programmability that they
can consume is different.
And it's a spectrum.
It's not the same for everybody.
For many, usability is
extremely important.
And so my mission
in life really has
been still build open system.
Still build system that
is truly programmable.
Build system that is open
API, open data model.
But also, build
usability on top,
where, if somebody wants to
consume a truly modern system,
they can without having to
really build the development
team that Google
has or can afford.
And that has been a learning--
sort of talking to, really,
spending a lot of time
with customers and seeing
they all have the same need.
I think Anna was
making the point
that Google is not a bubble.
Ultimately, everybody has need
for similar infrastructure,
whether they consume
it from cloud
or whether they
consume it internally.
But making it usable
for them and making
it usable without having
to make it proprietary,
there is a bit of
a tension in there.
But I think it's doable,
and that has been my goal.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: And then
the last question for Anna,
and then we'll open up to one or
two questions for the audience.
Like today, people saw the
Traffic Director announcement.
They know you're
heavily involved.
As you ship out all of these
Google-specific products,
should they use it, or should
they be worried about lock-in?
ANNA BERENBERG: Traffic
Director has open interface
to Envoy's or any
XTS-compliant proxy.
So it's the way to merge
together all the value
proposition as Google
developed over these 15 years
with the open interfaces
and essentially
producing open systems.
So let's say you use
Traffic Director today.
And tomorrow, you decided
you don't want to use it.
You build your
own control plane.
There's nothing that locks
you in into Traffic Director,
because you just switch
your point at which you're
sending these APIs.
And you get a different
control plane functionality
over the same APIs.
We're hopeful that
you're not going
to switch away, because
we are providing
amazing functionality.
But I'm not going
to be selling here.
But in general, as long as
you have open interfaces,
there is no vendor lock-in.
So in my mind, the
data plane needs
to be universally open
source, like Envoy or JRPC,
that is without a proxy.
This basic transport
needs to be open source.
And then you have control planes
that are sitting on top of it,
with open APIs, which are
also removing vendors lock-in.
And then the cloud providers
can compete on the value
proposition behind these APIs.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So I
did want the audience--
I want to give them the chance
to ask one or two questions.
And then you can find
them after the talk,
because I do want to end
with their perspective.
If you want to ask a
question, we probably
have only time for one or two.
But just use one of the
mics so everybody can hear.
AUDIENCE: Just a
question for you
with regards to
Mongo's experiment
with the server-side license.
What do you think
Mongo should have done?
And what do you feel about the
community's reaction to it?
No volunteers?
MATT KLEIN: Well, you
know, this is actually
what I was talking about before.
Look, no one does anything in
this industry out of goodwill,
right?
I mean, let's just be honest.
We're all here
probably to make--
[LAUGHTER]
We're all here to make
money in some way.
Some of us are selling
infrastructure.
Some of us are
building businesses.
But very few of us, if we're
really honest with ourselves,
are here because this is the
best thing that we can be
doing on Wednesday afternoon.
So with that said, if you look
around at people's motivations,
they're trying to build a
business out of their software.
The problem right now--
and I don't really
want to comment
on Mongo or Redis,
just because everyone has
their own business situation
that they're in.
But this is directly
related to what
I was saying before
about why I didn't start
my own company, which is, there
is a tension between locking
down open systems and software
and trying to charge people
for those systems versus
building a welcoming, larger
community, which is extensible,
and then allows everyone
to succeed.
And this is very subtle.
I've written a blog
post on this, which you
could check out, if you want.
But I think there
are ways of building
viable vertical
businesses on top
without alienating
people on locking down
certain pieces of the software.
So what I would say, again,
without specifically commenting
on particular
companies, I think there
are ways that it can
be done, but it's
a very complicated problem.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI:
So we can probably
take one more question.
Oh, you wanted to add?
Go ahead.
BIKASH KOLEY:
Maybe I'll add, not
answering specifically
to MongoDB, again,
because I don't know what their
business model specifically is.
I think there is a misconception
that open source is free.
It's not free.
The software developers
have to make a living
by writing software
somehow, and there
has to be a business model
somehow for the software
developers to make
money, to make a living.
The part that I found
is very important
is to be very clear
about the business model
that you have around open
source, which sometimes is not
true.
And changing the business
model mid-course actually
can be very problematic
for the community.
And that's the problem.
The problem is, if we don't
have the business model laid out
very clearly from day
one, Tungsten Fabric
has a business model
of open core, where
the stuff that is open
source will always
remain open source, period.
It doesn't matter whether
a Juniper competition
is building a product with
us at Tungsten Fabric.
It's going to
remain open source,
because that's the charter
in Linux Foundation.
And I think, having that
clarity with the business model
is important, because
otherwise, people
build this mistaken assumption
that somehow open source is
free.
And now, you try to figure
out how to monetize it.
And that's the problem.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Kelsey says,
let's take some more questions.
So let's take some
more questions.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: We can be
really tight with our answers
as well.
I mean, you guys
are here in person.
So we appreciate that
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: And it's
your panel, so go for it.
If you want to ask questions,
just use one of the mics,
though, so everybody can hear.
AUDIENCE: The way
I see Kubernetes
is that it's a level playing
field for the way you
build and deploy
containerized applications.
And Kubernetes is
available both on-prem
and all the public clouds.
Do we need an answer for
network security storage
that's similar to Kubernetes?
And do we have an answer?
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
The thing is, I
think, you're going
to need someone
with that level of
experience willing to build
a system in a very similar way
that Envoy did and Kubernetes
did, and, I think, that's
going to be very hard.
We saw it with Git, with
Sourcetree management.
We saw it with Linux.
So I think a lot of people
have the right motivations,
but you need all
the other factors.
And I think it's very rare
that you'll see an Envoy come
from a place that it came from.
I think it needs to solve a
real problem first for at least
one company first
and put it out there.
And if people think it
can be generic enough
that a lot of people
want to use it,
I think that'll work out well.
We saw this with HTTP.
There's a standard around it.
Lots of people can implement it.
But the problem with networking,
it's a lot of cultural things
that are baked into how
you lay out your network.
There's different architectures.
To me, networking is closer
to programming languages.
You can decide what architecture
you want your network to take.
Some infosec teams won't give
out more than 10 IP addresses.
They count them, like, no,
no, no, these are private IPs,
I can give you 10.
It's like, what the hell
are you doing with them?
They're fake, actually.
You can make more of them.
It's very cultural.
To me, I think the
networking problem
is that it's so cultural
for these companies,
if I gave you the
best networking
tool, like in Kubernetes,
the culture is going
to dictate how it gets used.
That's the features
you're going to ask.
So I think Kubernetes
is a little bit easier,
because again,
you're just making
some system calls, wrap up your
code, put it in a container.
It's going to run it for you.
So I don't know.
Some of them may try to do it.
I think Envoy gets
us very close.
But in terms of how you lay
out architected framework
for your internal network,
I don't know about that one.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Any
other questions?
We can probably take one more.
Otherwise, I want to put the
panelists on the hot spots.
So I can do that instead.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: Do it.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Do it?
OK.
So each of you, I think
you rightly pointed out
that different companies have
different motivations for doing
all of this.
When I look at each one of
you, there are several things,
as Kelsey pointed out, we
have a very heavy-duty title
for this talk.
And so I wanted to
put each of the folks
here on the hot seat to
answer a few questions.
We spoke so much
about open systems
and making the switch from
whatever your deployment is
today, and then
somehow migrating it
to whatever your end
goal is, so bringing
all of this to your brownfield
and so on and so forth.
But if you, let's say, look
two to three years ahead,
let's say, we have all
of these open systems.
We have all of these paradigms.
What has it enabled?
What kind of
businesses do you see?
What kind of problems solved?
What kind of communities?
Are we even going to be talking
about Kubernetes, and Envoy,
and Server Smash,
and all of that two,
three years down the line?
Or will the conversation
be totally different?
And maybe we can start
with you, Bikash.
BIKASH KOLEY: So I think the
very nature of applications
and users are evolving, so it's
a given that the infrastructure
is going to evolve.
I think that's one thing
that we know for sure.
Everything else is
pretty much a guess.
I do think that being open
is a necessity in the world
that we live in.
And the reason being,
ultimately, now, sometimes
I get this question
of, what is cloud?
It's a set of stable
APIs on an infrastructure
that the APIs hide from you.
That's what it is.
And of course,
the infrastructure
evolves over time.
It's true for
everybody, whether it's
public cloud or private cloud.
It's the well-defined
abstractions in API
that make it durable
and usable, right?
So I think the need for
open is coming from the fact
that you want a part
of the infrastructure
that you can use for
a long period of time,
while the underlying
scaffoldings will
change over time.
And you don't have to
reinvent your infrastructure
every single time.
So I think we've seen that.
If you look back 20 years
in how [INAUDIBLE] was done,
the basic Unix system calls
haven't changed that much.
[? Downlink ?] scaffoldings
have significantly changed.
MATT KLEIN: I think
my view and the thing
that I typically tell people is
that all of us that are sitting
here building
infrastructure, we're
doing it to support application
developers building business
logic.
That's the entire point.
I mean, infrastructure
is overhead.
There's no point to it, right?
The way that people make money
is by writing business logic.
So I think my goal-- and
this is not a three year out.
This is more of a
five to 10 year out.
I think ultimately, I do
believe in the, quote,
"serverless paradigms."
And just by that, I mean that
in the long run, as Kelsey
was saying, you want people
to write code, and store data,
and talk to things.
That's it.
That's all application
developers care about that.
They don't care about
container systems.
They don't care
about networking.
They don't care about routing.
They don't care about failover.
And so I guess, my
view is that our goal
is to make it so that no
one even cares or knows
about Kubernetes.
They don't care or
know about Envoy.
Envoy is a transparent thing
that provides functionality,
and all people are doing
is the fundamentals.
And we're so far away
from that right now.
And that's what
excites me is that we
have many years of building
better abstractions and better
systems so that
the fundamentals,
they just get to people
in a much simpler fashion.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER:
Yeah, so I think,
if you look at
programming languages,
like if you look at neural
programming languages--
I would even put Python in
that category and Golang--
they have very extensive
standard libraries.
Go has this very
robust HTP server,
where typically, you don't
need to front it with anything.
And a lot of the libraries that
you see in the standard library
allow you to compose
just software that's
ready to go on the network.
That was Go's goal.
If you think about this from
the platform perspective,
so platforms are evolving from
these bare-metal machines,
Linux systemd init systems.
And now that were
in this Kubernetes
era, serverless eras, I think
Kubernetes and Envoy just
become standard
libraries for platforms.
If you're going to
build a platform
to talk about
Matt's goal, you're
just going to look at these
as standard libraries.
All right, I need somebody
to handle this network layer.
I need something to
handle the compute layer.
You just going to import
those into your stack.
And the thing that
you build on top
will be that higher level thing.
That's what Go's
trying to do for you.
You build programming logic.
You don't think
about SSL handshakes.
about HTP handshakes.
All you do is
import that library.
You write your handler,
and you handle the request.
These things that
we're working on
is all so you can have
that platform at top.
So I think that's
the best way to start
thinking about the
future of these things.
Start at, what do
you want to do?
What's the minimum
required to do it?
And all the things
that are getting
in your way of the minimal
requirement, that's
the things that we probably need
to fit, flesh out, and build.
But that's the thing
that will underpin
the long-term platform.
ANNA BERENBERG: I agree with
everything being said here.
But I always say that in five
years, network will disappear.
Nobody wants to program
networking, right?
Find one developer who
actually interested in it.
So networking will
disappear, all
that contain management also.
And over here, you'll
have a different panel.
You'll have a panel of
business developers, who
are going to be talking to
each other how to federate,
how to make their
vertical into horizontals.
Because at that time,
the conversation
will move a layer up.
And I'm not saying that we're
going to become dinosaurs.
But by that time, we
either solve the problem,
or we're going to be
where we are today.
So we need to solve the problem
to become universal, very much
horizontal across
different environment,
make workloads be the same,
no matter where they run.
And basically, solve the
problem that we discussed today.
KELSEY HIGHTOWER: I
want to add one thing.
The time horizon,
everyone thinks
that this is five years away.
I was at KubeCon, and
everyone's talking
about Kubernetes and Service
Meshes, and all these things.
And there was a person, there
was a Google Cloud T-shirt.
They were a customer.
And they were like, I
am so glad we just used
App Engine eight years ago.
I don't care about any of that.
And they run a real business.
It's not a fancy startup.
They just don't care.
And they're like, why are
people trying to rebuild
App Engine from scratch?
And so the thing is, some
people have this reality.
I'm not saying that it's going
to be reality for everyone.
There are people who've had
this reality for a long time.
I think most people, they
just convinced themselves,
you're just trying to
build the same thing.
You just feel more comfortable
doing it from, I think,
the steps.
This is your stepping stones.
But if you step back--
and I tell a lot
of our customers,
you really want to build
App Engine from scratch?
I'll show you how.
But just know that's
what you're doing.
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: Yes, I think the
reason for getting all of these
folks here-- and we're almost
at the end of the panel,
because they wouldn't
give us more time--
but the reason for
bringing all of these folks
into these conversations
are starting--
these are just the beginnings
of a lot of conversations
that are on open
systems, open interfaces.
As each one of us here
goes and builds out
these technologies
in open source,
even within Google, at Juniper,
and so on and so forth,
and the whole goal
was to get you folks
as well thinking about
the open interfaces.
Also, how whatever
it is that you build
has a value for the community to
also benefit from that and also
your own business as well.
Because everybody is in it to
create a business out of things
or to solve a
particular problem.
And so one of the things
I highly encourage
is to also engage with
these folks on Twitter,
LinkedIn, other forums, and then
keep the conversations going.
So thank you for coming, and
thanks to all of our panelists.
Please give them a big hand.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]